This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是来自I-Heart的一个播客。绝对真人。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）主持的《迎难而上》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个节目探讨黑人男性的真实经历，进行那些在别处实在不安全、无法公开的坦诚对话，而这一切都是与一位深谙此道的持牌专业人士共同完成的。有多少男人披着一身铠甲？它向世界释放出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须得这么做，聆听并学习。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
用硬核的方式在AHA广播应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上。2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控令人生下双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。为了揭露一个令人不安的模式，网络侦探们可以说是出动了一大批人。另外两名经历过同样事情的男性：格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我当时惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。请在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《深陷爱河》播客。2%。这就是当电梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在这个奇怪的现代世界中，如何建立心理韧性、保持体能以及培养复原力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你最终将成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的自己。请在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《2%》。《2%》这个名字就是这样来的。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说
trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is great to have you here back for another episode. Today, we're going to talk about the incredible power of self-forgiveness and how to embrace our past mistakes. I think we have a really difficult time accepting the
相信你的闺蜜。请在Iheart radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《闺蜜：相信我，宝贝》。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》（The psychology of your 20s），这是一个探讨我们二十岁时所经历的重大生活变化与过渡，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听友、老听友，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里，收听新的一期节目。今天，我们将探讨自我宽恕的不可思议的力量，以及如何接纳我们过去的错误。我觉得我们很难接受这样一个
fact that each of us is innately flawed. We are an innately flawed species and we often ruminate on all the things that we've gotten wrong, sometimes for months or even years after the fact. I am very much the same, but I've come to realize recently that not accepting our failures, not accepting our mistakes kind of means not accepting the fact that we are human and putting our behavior on a pedestal that we would never place someone else on. This is particularly relevant for our 20s and our early years as adults because it is a time of exploration, of learning and growth, but I think also this weird decade or limbo between childhood and adolescent feelings and that adulthood maturity where so many of the things we are experiencing, we are experiencing for the
事实：我们每个人生来都是有缺陷的。我们是一个天生有缺陷的物种，我们经常反复咀嚼那些我们做错了的事情，有时甚至在事后几个月或几年里依然如此。我自己也是这样，但我最近意识到，不接受我们的失败，不接受我们的错误，某种程度上就意味着不接受我们是人类这一事实，并且将我们的行为放在了一个我们绝不会用来要求别人的高标准高架子上。这对于我们的二十岁以及初入社会的几年尤为相关，因为这是一个探索、学习和成长的时期，但我也认为，这也是一个介于童年与青春期情感和成年成熟度之间的奇妙十年或灰色地带，在这个阶段，我们体验到的许多事情，都是我们
first time. And as frustrating as it is, we don't really have a guidebook. A lot of it comes down to trial and error, from impulsive relationship choices to career plans that don't really work out as expected. And unfortunately, sometimes mistakes that end up hurting other people, even if we didn't mean to. So how can we embrace this unfortunate but kind of unavoidable side of ourselves? I think that's a huge question. because living with regret and guilt truly gets us nowhere. Unfortunately, I think you cannot undo the past, but you also can't live with that remorse forever.
第一次经历。尽管这让人感到沮丧，但我们其实并没有一本现成的指南。很多事情归根结底都要靠反复试错，从冲动的恋爱选择到并不如预期般顺利的职业规划。而不幸的是，有时这些错误最终会伤害到其他人，哪怕我们并非本意。那么，我们该如何接纳这不幸却又不可避免的自己的一部分呢？我认为这是一个巨大的问题。因为带着遗憾和内疚生活确实带我们去不到任何地方。不幸的是，我认为你无法撤销过去，但你也不能永远背负着这种懊悔生活。
The beauty of psychology lies in its ability to really shed light on our human experience, but also our capacity to grow, despite all the things that we think have ruined our lives or we think make us bad people. I promise that those mistakes do not mean, those things. We're going to explore in today's episode the very neurology and underpinning psychological theories that show why our 20s are important for making mistakes. We're also going to look at the distinction between feeling regret and feeling guilty, especially when we do come
心理学的美妙之处在于它能够真正照亮我们的真实人类体验，同时也展现了我们的成长能力——尽管有那么多我们以为已经毁了我们生活、或者我们认为让我们成为坏事之人的事情。我向大家保证，那些错误并不意味着那些事情。在今天的节目中，我们将探讨神经科学和支撑心理学理论，这些理论表明为什么我们的二十岁对于犯错至关重要。我们还将探讨感到遗憾与感到内疚之间的区别，尤其是当我们真正意识到
to acknowledge that we've hurt others. There's a reason we hold on to those experiences, and it has a lot to do with social harmony and social contract theory, but also this conflict between our actual selves and our idea selves. Beyond that, we're also going to discuss why it is that some people experience regret more profoundly than others, particularly due to factors like rumination, but also on a controversial note, maybe, the role of social media in weaponising, public shame. That is all very valuable information to understand, but what we're really here for is to get into a place where we can practice self-forgiveness and learn how to forgive yourself
我们伤害了他人时。我们之所以紧抓着这些经历不放是有原因的，这在很大程度上与社会和谐以及社会契约理论有关，同时也与我们的现实自我和理想自我之间的这种冲突有关。除此之外，我们还将探讨为什么有些人比其他人更深切地体验到遗憾，特别是由于反刍思维等因素，而且可能是一个有争议的话题，即社交媒体在将公众羞耻武器化方面所扮演的角色。所有这些都是非常宝贵的理解信息，但我们真正来到这里的目的，是进入一个能够练习自我宽恕的境界，并学会原谅自己
for the times that you didn't know any better than you do now. It's part of our shared humanity to mess up. And I do truly believe that we can learn just as much, if not more, from our mistakes as we can from our successes. So I also want to dive into the four hours of self-forgiveness and how accountability, although initially unpleasant, can really free you from a lot of lifelong guilt and negativity. It really comes down to self-compassion. And by releasing ourselves from that kind of chains and those chains of self-blame through genuine actual introspection and self-awareness, we really do unlock the potential to use the things in our past for growth rather than letting us or letting ourselves really be weighed down by that. So a lot of the advice
那些在当时还不如现在懂事的时刻。犯错是我们共同人性的一部分。而且我坚信，我们从错误中学到的东西，绝对不亚于从成功中学到的东西，甚至可能更多。因此，我也想深入探讨自我宽恕的“四个R”（四个原则），以及问责制虽然一开始并不愉快，但如何能真正将你从一生的内疚和负面情绪中解放出来。这归根结底还是要靠自我同情。通过真正深刻的内省和自我意识，将自己从那种自我责怪的链条和枷锁中解放出来，我们才能真正释放出潜能，利用过去的经历来促进成长，而不是让自己被这些过去真正压垮。所以，我们将要探讨的许多建议
and the evidence we're going to explore is probably information that I needed to take on myself. If you're listening to this, I'm guessing you're most likely in your 20s and I am as well. So we are all learning together and sometimes we're not going to be perfect. But at least we can be in the same boat, so I'm excited to get into it. Without further ado, let's explore the psychology behind self-forgiveness and moving on from our past mistakes. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with
和证据可能正是我自己也需要吸收的信息。如果你正在听这个节目，我猜你很可能也处于二十多岁，而我也是。所以我们都在共同学习，有时我们不会做到完美。但至少我们都在同一条船上，所以我很高兴能深入探讨这个话题。废话不多说，让我们一起来探索自我宽恕背后的心理学，以及如何走出过去的错误。2%。这就是当电梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在这个奇怪的现代世界中，如何建立心理韧性、保持体能以及培养复原力的科学。我将与
with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled healthier person. Listen to 2%.
作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以看穿那些充斥着健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经坚信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题实际上都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你最终将成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的自己。请收听《2%》。
That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett.
这就是在I-Hart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《TWO%》。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在MTV音乐录影带大奖（VMAs）上双击小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和金·卡戴珊到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特（Sam Jett）。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
我是亚历克斯·英格利斯（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会精选一个事件，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。其中包括最近的一集，马马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）畅谈80年代的快克可卡因。坦白说，1984对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。只要你们想知道，我随时准备聊聊快克。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了，所以我开始看出这其中有一条主线了。我们现在甚至把艾滋病也摆上台面了。
Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
谢谢你把那句话说完。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《回顾过去》。欢迎来到我的新播客《迎难而上》（Learn the Hard Way），我是主持人、也是你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将把我在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。
I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross.
我要说的是。特里普·方丹（Trip Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，在我们追求某样东西的过程中，我们太过于沉迷于追逐本身，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们却仍在继续追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是盯着记分牌。生活变成了一场关于胜利与失败的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。
Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing,
因为你觉得在这个世界上做一个好人很重要。你之所以是个好人，是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。这是两个不同信任层面的问题。我希望你能够真正地做一个好人。加入我凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）的行列，在我的新播客《迎难而上》中，就疗愈、
growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed
成长、父职、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的Our Heart Radio应用。搜索《迎难而上》并立即收听。2023年，前单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己陷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法院听证会
revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
暴露出她故事中显而易见的自相矛盾之处。这引发了一场历时多年的法庭之争，旨在证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。为了破案，他们出动了一大批网络侦探。我希望人们能看到他们的税款都被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭露了一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男人：格雷格、勒斯比、迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我当时惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了法律的制裁。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。
This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Okay, it goes without saying that you are going to make a lot of mistakes. in your 20s and probably in every decade thereafter. Unfortunately for us, humans are highly fallible and flawed creatures. We cannot do everything perfectly, and that includes life. I think an important reminder is that none of us have done this before. This is your first time being alive, experiencing these events and complex emotions,
在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。请在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《深陷爱河》播客。好了，不言而喻的是，你在二十多岁的时候，
and just the ways of human error and misunderstanding and learning. And so despite our best intentions, we are going to mess up and we might hurt other people and experience regret. I think despite the unavoidability of mistakes, we do have a choice to let this, A, completely paralyze us and perpetually hate ourselves or be, embrace the opportunity this provides and embrace our mistakes for exactly what they are, which is a space for self-awareness and for growth. I think it's important to remember as we're discussing forgiving ourselves for past mistakes that you are not the same person you were two years ago or even six months ago. People can grow and change and realize the error of their ways. There is not a single person out there who hasn't done something they wish they could take back. But it's about how you move forward from that, whether you take on the responsibility of what you've done.
以及之后的每一个十年里，都会犯下很多错误。对我们人类而言不幸的是，人类是极易犯错且充满瑕疵的生物。我们无法把每件事都做到完美，生活也是如此。我认为一个重要的提醒是，我们所有人以前都没有经历过这一切。这是你第一次活着，体验这些事件和复杂的情感，
of, you know, some of the errors of your ways. Additionally, when applying self-compassion in these situations, I think it's important to recognize that our 20s in particular are a time when we are going to mess up probably more than any other decade for a number of reasons. This era of our lives involves a very unique blend of still feeling very much like a child, but being expected to behave like an adult. It's like as soon as the clock kind of strikes 12 on your 18th birthday, suddenly we're expected to mature into this whole new version of ourselves who can pay taxes and own a home and is expected to understand exactly what they want and how to treat others. But that's not really how maturity works from a psychological, emotional, social perspective.
以及人类犯错、误解和学习的方式。因此，尽管我们怀着最好的意愿，我们还是会搞砸，可能会伤害到其他人并体验到遗憾。我认为，尽管错误是不可避免的，但我们确实有一种选择：要么A，让这件事完全使我们瘫痪并永远自我憎恶；要么B，拥抱它所带来的机遇，并把我们的错误视其本来面目——也就是一个进行自我认知和生长的空间。我认为在讨论原谅自己过去的错误时，有一点很重要，那就是你已经不是两年前甚至六个月前的那个自己了。人们会成长、改变，并意识到自己行为中的错误。没有哪个人从来没有做过一件希望自己能收回的事。但关键在于你将如何从中继续前行，你是否承担起了你所做之事的责任，
And so our 20s are this unique in between time, I would say, where we're grappling with two different, sides of ourselves, the immaturity, but also the expectation of responsibility. And we have no idea what's going on. A lot of the time, we do not have the hindsight to understand the future consequences of our current actions. Speaking from a very neurological perspective as well, our brains also don't completely finish developing and maturing until like the late to mid-20s. and the last part of our brain to mature is called the prefrontal cortex. We speak about this a lot because it is such a crucial part of everything that makes us very human, our personality, our identity, but it's also the area responsible for things like decision
也就是你某些错误行为的责任。此外，在这些情况下运用自我同情时，我认为重要的是要认识到，特别是我们的二十岁，是我们比其他任何十年都更有可能犯错的时期，原因有很多。我们人生中的这个阶段包含了一种非常独特的混合状态：一方面觉得自己仍然是个孩子，另一方面却被期望表现得像个成年人。这就好比只要你18岁生日那天时针一过12点，我们突然就被期望成熟为一个全新版本的自己，一个能够纳税、拥有房产、并且被期望确切知道自己想要什么以及如何对待他人的人。但从心理、情感和社会的角度来看，成熟并不是这样运作的。
making and impulse control. It's why when we look back at things that we did at 17, when our prefrontal cortex was not developed, we kind of internally cringe. I was talking to someone about this the other day who I think knew me or met me when I was maybe 19 or 20 and she was telling me about her first impression of me and how she thought I was super loud and didn't really think before I spoke. And I was like, yeah, that's probably right. I made a lot of mistakes back then and did things I really regret that I look back at now with that prefrontal maturity and just cannot fathom. there's so much in there and so much in our history that I think we realize we would have done
因此，二十岁是一个独特的过渡期，我想说的是，在这个时期，我们正在与我们内心的两个不同侧面作斗争：不成熟，以及对责任的期望。而且我们根本不知道发生了什么。很多时候，我们并没有事后诸葛亮的智慧来理解当前行为对未来的影响。从神经学的角度来说，直到二十岁中后期，我们的大脑才算完全发育和成熟。而我们大脑最后成熟的部分被称为前额叶皮层。我们经常谈论这个部位，因为它是构成我们人类特质的核心部分——我们的个性、我们的身份，但它也是负责诸如决策
differently. We're also trying out different versions of ourselves, some of which may not fit, or versions that don't actually reflect our values. This is also in part because we're trying to separate from the identity we have cultivated under the guidance of our family, particularly our parents and we're trying to branch out to be our own independent people. Suddenly, the protective kind of shield of parental supervision is taken down and you've got to learn all the things they learned in their 20s and that is a lot of trial and error and ultimately a few regrets. Also, when we combine that with things like the drinking age, you know, that a lot of us start consuming alcohol during this period. We know that leads to poor a
和冲动控制等功能的区域。这就是为什么当我们回首17岁时做过的事情——当时我们的前额叶皮层尚未发育完全——内心会感到一阵尴尬。前几天我和某人谈起这件事，她可能是在我19或20岁时认识或遇到我的，她跟我讲了她对我的第一印象，说她觉得我超级吵闹，说话前也不怎么过脑子。当时我就想，是的，那大概没错。我那时犯了很多错误，做了一些我现在回想起来、凭借前额叶的成熟度简直无法想象、也深感后悔的事情。那里面包含了太多东西，在我们的过去中有太多事情，我想如果我们能重来，都会选择
decisions. We also have a bit more financial freedom. And also the complexity that develops in our relationships, it's kind of no wonder that we're going to misstep at times. We are going to do dumb things. We pass up amazing opportunities. We fail at things. We wish we'd succeeded. We spend too much money. We embarrass ourselves. However, amongst all of these mistakes, I think the biggest ones I see people ruminating on have to do with how they acted in their personal relationships, how they treated their friends or a former partner, maybe even their parents. I think without a doubt, these other regrets that sting the most, that leave kind of the greatest emotional scars. There's a reason why interpersonal regret sticks with us perhaps more so than the decisions
做得不一样。我们还在尝试不同版本的自己，其中一些版本可能并不适合我们，或者这些版本实际上并没有反映出我们的价值观。这部分原因也是因为我们正试图脱离在家庭、特别是父母的指导下培养出的身份认同，试图开辟出属于自己的独立人格。突然之间，父母监督的那种保护伞被撤掉了，你不得不去学习他们在二十多岁时学到的所有东西，而这伴随着大量的反复试错，归根结底，还有一些遗憾。此外，当我们把这些与诸如法定饮酒年龄之类的事情结合起来时，你知道，我们很多人都是在这个时期开始饮酒的。我们知道这会导致不良
that could only hurt us individually. We have evolved as creatures as a species who seek the need and the approval of the group for survival. And part of that is the need to create social harmony and behave according to the social agreement that really implicitly dictates how we treat others. In psychology and also in philosophy,
决策。我们也有了更多的财务自由。再加上人际关系中日益复杂的发展，难怪我们在某些时刻会走错路。我们会做一些愚蠢的事情。我们会错过绝佳的机会。我们会遭遇失败。我们会希望自己曾经成功过。我们会花掉太多钱。我们会让自己陷入尴尬。然而，在所有这些错误中，我发现人们反刍最多的、最深刻的错误，都与他们在人际关系中的行为方式有关，与他们如何对待朋友或前任伴侣、甚至可能是他们的父母有关。毫无疑问，这些才是最刺痛人、留下最深情感伤疤的遗憾。人际关系方面的遗憾之所以会留在我们心头挥之不去，甚至超过那些
there's this idea known as social contract theory and what it says is that we have been conditioned to live together in society in accordance with an inherent moral agreement to not hurt others or to not do on to others as we would want done onto ourselves. So causing someone else pain, either due to things like oversight or selfishness or even outright cruelty, it goes against that contract. Those feelings of regret, of guilt or shame, they are an indebt. internal psychological signal that we have gone against this deeper moral code and that we need to rectify our behavior to restore a general sense of cohesion. In that way, things like guilt, as they relate to past mistakes, are somewhat of a pro-social emotion. It's trying to make us a good person to be around. It's trying to show us how we can be agreeable and stick within that
可能只会伤害我们个人的决定，这是有原因的。作为一种生物和一个物种，我们在进化过程中一直寻求群体的需求和认可来求得生存。而其中的一部分就是需要建立社会和谐，并根据社会契约来行事，这些契约含蓄地规定了我们该如何对待他人。在心理学和哲学中，
social contract. There's an important distinction here between guilt and regret, because I think although sometimes we use them interchangeably, as I literally just did, there is a bit of a difference. In a study they conducted back in 2012, maybe 2011, they got people to describe typical situations in which they felt guilt and situations where they felt regret. What they found is that guilt specifically occurs for choices in a social context where we have believed that we have caused harm, whereas regret is strongly associated with personal mistakes, with missed opportunities, self-sabotage, that kind of broader category of behaviours. When we wrong someone else, this is where we typically experience guilt and we regret the actions
有一个被称为社会契约理论的观点，它表明我们被塑造成共同生活在社会中，并遵循一项内在的道德协议：不伤害他人，或者不把我们自己不愿承受的事强加给他人。因此，由于疏忽、自私甚至是彻底的残忍而给他人带来痛苦，是违背这一契约的。那些遗憾、内疚或羞耻的感觉，是一种内在的心理信号，表明我们违背了更深层的道德准则，我们需要纠正自己的行为以恢复普遍的凝聚力。从这个意义上说，诸如内疚之类的、与过去错误相关的情感，在某种程度上是一种亲社会的情感。它试图让我们成为一个招人喜爱的人。它试图向我们展示我们如何才能做到讨人喜欢并坚守这一
that cause this pain, the actions that we were responsible for. regret, self-pity, that is for the self, whereas guilt and remorse is for others. I want to pause and actually break down the psychology behind regret for a second here, because I think that is the primary emotion we're discussing when we examine the long-term impact of past mistakes. A regret at its core is a complex emotion that arises when we feel dissatisfied or disappointed with past choices. And it, often stems from a desire to have done things differently based on our current perspective. And this kind of occurs in two directions. So we can regret the things that we didn't do,
社会契约。这里有一个关于内疚和遗憾的重要区别，因为我认为有时我们会交替使用这两个词，正如我刚才所做的那样，但它们之间确实存在一些细微的差别。在他们于2012年（或许是2011年）进行的一项研究中，研究人员让人们描述他们感到内疚的典型情境，以及他们感到遗憾的情境。他们发现，内疚专门发生在社会环境中的选择上，在这些选择中，我们认为自己造成了伤害，而遗憾则与个人错误、错过的机会、自我破坏以及更广泛的行为类别密切相关。当我们做错了事伤害了别人时，这通常是我们体验到内疚的地方，而我们则为那些导致这种痛苦的行为、我们负有责任的行为感到遗憾。
which is what we would call inaction, all the things that we did do, which is called actionable or action regret. And importantly, you're more likely to experience long-term regret for the times when you didn't act compared to the decisions that you did make. Research suggests that there's action-related regrets, although they're painful, they actually spur people to learn more from their mistakes and move on, because they've given us an experience that we otherwise wouldn't have had, and we wouldn't have had that teachable moment. But regret related to an action, the things that we cannot do, the opportunities that we did lose,
遗憾、自怜，那是为了自己，而内疚和懊悔则是为了他人。我想暂停一下，在这里剖析一下遗憾背后的心理学，因为我认为这是我们审视过去错误的长期影响时讨论的主要情感。遗憾在其核心上是一种复杂的情感，当我们对过去的选择感到不满或失望时，它就会产生。它往往源于一种愿望：基于我们当前的视角，希望当初能做出不同的事情。这种情绪在两个方向上发生。所以我们可以对我们没有做的事情感到遗憾，
it's much harder to fix. And this kind of regret is more associated with things like long-term anxiety, depression, a feeling of stuckness. So if you want to avoid future regret, I think it kind of goes without saying that it's more about making a decision than making the wrong decision. Because even if it's the wrong decision, then it's better than doing nothing at all because it will at least give you a teachable
这就是我们所说的不作为，或者对我们确实做了的事情感到遗憾，这被称为可作为的行动遗憾。重要的是，比起你实际做出的决定，你更有可能为那些没有采取行动的时刻体验到长期的遗憾。研究表明，与行动相关的遗憾虽然令人痛苦，但实际上会促使人们从错误中吸取更多教训并继续前进，因为它们给了我们一段本来不会有的经历，如果没有那一次，我们就不会有那个可以教导我们的时刻。但与不作为相关的遗憾，那些我们无法完成的事情，我们失去的机会，
moment compared to just the regret surrounding the what if, the expectant thinking, the kind of hypothetical future telling and what if it had turned out differently? What if I had actually done this? You can't really take that back. However, further to this idea of the mistakes that we make that hurt others, there's this idea known as discrepancy theory that explains why these mistakes linger the most. Each of us has an actual self, which is who, who we actually are and an ideal self, the person we would like to be. And when the actions conducted by our actual self don't align with our ideal self, that is when we experience things like regret or negative emotions,
则要难得多去修复。而这种遗憾更多地与长期焦虑、抑郁、一种受困感联系在一起。因此，如果你想避免未来的遗憾，我觉得不言而喻的是，这更多在于做出一个决定，而不是做出正确的决定。因为即使这是一个错误的决定，也总比什么都不做好，因为它至少能给你一个吸取教训的时刻，而不是仅仅围绕着“如果当初……”、期待性的思维、假设性的未来预测以及“如果事情结果不同会怎样？如果我真的那样做了会怎样？”这些遗憾打转。你真的无法撤回那些假设。然而，除了我们所犯下的伤害他人的错误这一想法之外，
because we are not acting in accordance with who we feel we ought to be. When we don't act, we regret our wasted potential. When we do, we regret the outcome of those actions. And we experience regret for a few other reasons. We already spoke of the kind of evolutionary explanation, especially from a social perspective, where we don't want to disrupt social harmony. But regret also serves to prevent us making the same mistake twice.
还有一个被称为差异理论（discrepancy theory）的概念，它解释了为什么这些错误会挥之不去。我们每个人都有一个现实自我，也就是我们实际是谁，以及一个理想自我，也就是我们希望成为的人。当我们的现实自我所实施的行动与我们的理想自我不一致时，我们就会体验到遗憾或负面情绪之类的东西，
Past experiences in that way, they kind of linger in our brains as a cautionary tale. They want us to make better choices, better decisions, by using the emotional salience of that memory and the pain of that memory to dissuade us. Interestingly, psychological research indicates that while people often view regret to be distressing, it nevertheless is rated as a positive experience because when we listen to that remorse or that unpleasant sensation, we only need to experience the negative outcome once. When we don't listen, we keep making the same mistake over and over.
因为我们的行事方式与我们认为自己应当成为的人不符。当我们不采取行动时，我们会为浪费的潜力感到遗憾。当我们付诸行动时，我们会为这些行动的结果感到遗憾。我们体验到遗憾还有其他一些原因。我们之前已经讨论过某种进化解释，特别是从社会的角度来看，我们不希望破坏社会和谐。但遗憾也可以起到防止我们重蹈覆辙的作用。
again until that feeling finally sets in and by then there is a lot more to process and a lot more to reflect on so we're going to talk about that a little bit later how kind of going further into the belly of regret and acknowledging when you've made a mistake might actually help you not make future mistakes but i also want to speak about why there are some people in our lives maybe you are one of them who really finds it additionally an extra difficult to move on, to let these things go. Some people are more prone to lingering on things of the past. This is a tendency that we call rumination. So rumination is a thought processing disorder where we obsess over negative feelings and our distress and we repetitively think about all of the consequences,
从这个意义上说，过去的经历作为一种警示故事在我们的脑海中挥之不去。它们希望我们做出更好的选择、更好的决定，利用该记忆的情感显著性和痛苦来劝阻我们。有趣的是，心理学研究表明，尽管人们通常认为遗憾是令人痛苦的，但它仍然被评为一种积极的体验，因为当我们倾听这种懊悔或不愉快的感受时，我们只需要经历一次负面结果。如果我们不听，我们就会一次又一次地犯同样的错误，
how awful we are, all the things we could have avoided, what we've missed out on. our tendency to ruminate often comes from our coping style, particularly an individual tendency to overthink, but also things like emotional intelligence. So emotional intelligence really exacerbates our mental distress sometimes because we are unable to shut our brain off. Our brain, especially the brain of someone with high EQ, is constantly mulling over all of the emotional impacts and kind of roots and paths and branches of the ratches of their actions. People who also constantly ruminate, they may do so because they're unhappy with
直到那种感觉最终深入人心，而到那时，会有更多的事情需要去处理，更多的事情需要去反思。所以我们稍后会讨论这个问题——更深入地走进遗憾的腹地并承认自己犯了错误，实际上可能如何帮助你避免未来的错误。但我也想谈谈为什么我们生活中的某些人——也许你就是其中之一——会觉得放下这些事情、让它们过去格外困难。有些人更容易对过去的事情念念不忘。这种倾向我们称之为反刍思维（rumination）。反刍思维是一种思维处理障碍，我们会沉迷于负面情绪和痛苦中，并反复思考所有的后果、
the lack of closure from an experience and they use overthinking to kind of soothe that distress. But it actually does the opposite. It gets us stuck in the negative cycle and unable to move past our past actions. Dwelling upon mistakes, it has been shown time and time again that although it might feel like you're doing something about it, what is actually happening is that you're going to diminish your self-confidence, you're going to diminish your creativity, you're going to diminish your performance and your productivity, and it's just going to make you feel absolutely miserable. And they did a series of studies in the early 2000s, and what they found was that when you dwell on past behavior, this can really trigger things like procrastination and perfectionism
我们有多么糟糕、所有我们本可以避免的事情、我们错过了什么。我们倾向于反刍往往来自于我们的应对方式，特别是个人过度思考的倾向，但也包括诸如情商之类的因素。情商有时确实会加剧我们的精神痛苦，因为我们无法关闭自己的大脑。我们的大脑，特别是高情商之人的大脑，在不断琢磨所有的情感冲击以及他们行为带来的种种根源、路径和分支。那些不断反刍的人，也可能是因为他们对一次经历缺乏闭环（Closure）感到不满意，
because you're so concerned that you might do it again. This is what makes regret so all-consuming. We cannot undo the past, no matter how hard we try. And yet we are thinking as if we can, that all of that mental energy is going to change the outcome. I think that sometimes this stems from our need for self-punishment. If we can't undo our mistakes, then we better make sure we repent for them
并利用过度思考来舒缓那种痛苦。但它实际上却起到了相反的作用。它让我们陷入消极的循环中，无法走出过去的行动。事实一次又一次地表明，沉溺于错误中，尽管你可能会觉得你正在为此做些什么，但实际发生的事情是，你会削弱自信心、削弱创造力、削弱表现和生产力，并且只会让你感到绝对痛苦。他们在2000年代初做了一系列研究，发现当你沉溺于过去的行为时，这确实会引发诸如拖延症和完美主义之类的事情，
or feel the full force of our guilt. Once again, some of that is evolutionary, and most of it is highly unproductive, and it stems from our deep sense of shame. So self-punishment involves things like forcing yourself to continually think about your mistakes, avoiding things that make you happy because you feel like you no longer deserve them, negative self-talk, excessive exercise, or even abusing things like alcohol. The use of self-punishment acts to relieve our guilt, but also in some ways makes us feel like we're redeeming ourselves. And when we face regret, perhaps due to inaction,
因为你太担心自己可能会再次犯错了。这就是为什么遗憾如此消耗心力。无论我们如何努力，都无法撤销过去。然而我们的思考方式却好像我们能做到一样，所有的这些精神能量都无法改变结果。我认为有时这源于我们对自我惩罚的需求。如果我们无法撤销我们的错误，那么我们最好确保为之忏悔，或者感受内疚的全部力量。再一次，其中一部分是进化的结果，而大部分则是极度缺乏生产力的，并且它源于我们深深的羞耻感。因此，自我惩罚包括强迫自己不断思考自己的错误、
we often feel like we lack a certain agency over our lives, particularly if we've acted out of character. And so self-punishment acts as an outlet, almost like a productive way to pay for our mistakes, we feel like it's doing something to counterbalance the negative experience of regret. Some of that is also imposed on us by society for sure. There's a reason why we may feel the pain of past mistakes more harshly nowadays, especially if they were things that were perhaps offensive or really hurt someone.
因为觉得自己不再配得上而避开那些让你快乐的事情、消极的自我对话、过度的锻炼，甚至滥用酒精等行为。自我惩罚的行为既能缓解我们的内疚，但在某种程度上也让我们觉得自己是在自我救赎。当我们面对遗憾时，也许是因为不作为，
Our society is really good at weaponizing shame for good. and for bad, especially things like online shaming and even cancel culture. I have a lot of opinions on this a lot. You know, we see celebrities being cancelled all the time, sometimes for very, very valid reasons. But when we see this play out so frequently, sometimes we feel that at any point that media outrage or even that personal outrage could be turned at us for minor things. We spend so much of our lives online. And so what people think of us in that context is important and we've become a lot more aware of how past actions which maybe at the time didn't seem so bad could now be deemed as really offensive or really hurtful.
我们常常觉得自己对生活缺乏某种主控权，特别是如果我们做出了有违本色的行为。因此，自我惩罚就像是一个宣泄口，几乎就像是一种为错误付出的具有建设性的方式，我们觉得这在某种程度上可以抵消遗憾的负面体验。当然，其中一部分也是社会强加给我们的。我们现在之所以对过去的错误感到更加痛苦，尤其是如果这些错误可能带有冒犯性或真正伤害了某人时，是有原因的。
I think that role of public humiliation, especially in the modern day, has a lot of complicated psychological and social origins that we don't really have time to get into. But what is definitely being seen, I think, is that it's really forcing us to reflect more on our actions and make us ask questions and question the distinction between maybe, I've done a bad thing and I regret it. And I'm a bad person. I can never be forgiven. Previously, our mistakes were not up for discussion by, you know, literally everyone on the internet. In the world now, like, you could do something stupid and it's everywhere.
我们的社会非常擅长将羞耻感武器化，无论是出于好的目的还是坏的目的，尤其是通过网络羞耻甚至取消文化（cancel culture）。对此我有很多很多的看法。你知道，我们看到名人们一直在被取消，有时是因为非常非常正当的理由。但当我们如此频繁地看到这一幕上演时，有时我们会觉得，在任何时候，这种媒体的愤怒甚至是个人的愤怒，都可能因为一些小事而转向我们。我们的很大一部分生活都在网上度过。因此，在这种背景下，人们对我们的看法非常重要，我们也变得更加意识到，过去那些在当时看来可能并不算太坏的行为，现在可能会被认为具有极强的冒犯性或伤害性。
someone could film you, and so we're much better at self-policing our behavior. On a micro kind of personal scale away from social media and the internet, I find our tendency to not forgive ourselves for past mistakes. Really fascinating and also at times quite ironic, because we are so, so willing to forgive other people when they do us harm. We are so willing to overlook hurtful behaviors, to realize that people make mistakes and maybe they've changed, maybe they've grown, but we hold ourselves to such a high standard.
我认为这种公开羞耻的角色，尤其是在现代，有着许多复杂的心理和社会渊源，我们没有足够的时间去深入探讨。但我认为可以肯定看到的是，它确实在迫使我们更多地反思自己的行为，并让我们提出问题，去质疑两者的区别：也许，“我做了一件坏事，我对此感到后悔”，与“我是一个坏人，我永远无法被原谅”。以前，我们的错误不会被互联网上的所有人拿来讨论。而在当今的世界里，你做了一件蠢事，它就会无处不在，
We don't give ourselves the same grace that we give others. I'm definitely someone who is highly forgiving, perhaps as some of my friends would say, to a fault sometimes. And I think that's because I would want to have the same forgiveness that I'm giving to others because of that sense that like we are a bad person. And one day we're going to need others to forgive us. So we'd better be very, very forgiving of them. without thinking of how we can forgive ourselves. But it's a lot deeper than that. We see others as
别人可以把你拍下来，所以我们在自我约束行为方面做得好多了。在一个微观的、个人的范围内，远离社交媒体和互联网，我发现我们倾向于不原谅自己过去错误的这种心理，真的非常迷人，有时也相当具有讽刺意味，因为当别人对我们造成伤害时，我们是如此、如此愿意原谅他们。我们如此愿意忽视那些伤害行为，去意识到人们会犯错，也许他们已经改变了，也许他们已经成长了，但我们却对自己抱持着如此高的标准。
very complex beings. We are very aware that they are flawed and they are nuanced. But we see ourselves as needing to be perfect and needing to have all the answers. That's what makes it so hard to move forward, especially since we're kind of the only ones who can personally and deeply feel all of the negative outcomes of our past, you know, especially that guilt. And we don't really see the private lives of others and how much they may themselves be self-punishing. Self-forgiveness is really tricky, but it's also truly the only way to move forward and such a positive character attribute. You've got to remind yourself that you truly did the best you could with the information
我们没有给予自己应有的那种对别人的宽容。我绝对是一个非常容易原谅别人的人，正如我的一些朋友所说，有时甚至有些过分地心软。我想那是因为我希望别人也能像我原谅他们那样原谅我，出于那种“我们都是不完美的人，总有一天我们会需要别人的原谅”的感觉。所以我们最好对他们非常非常宽容。却不去思考我们该如何原谅自己。但这要比那深刻得多。我们将其他人视为
you had. No one wants to make their lives worse. Most people don't want to hurt others or to experience regret. We don't want to be in this position. position. So if we knew the outcome of our decisions, we probably wouldn't have done it. We would have chosen differently. But we didn't. We didn't know what the consequences were going to be. We had to do what we thought was best, or at the very least, or very worst, what was convenient. And now, you know, as the saying goes, the bed has been made. You can't change it. But you can replace that
非常复杂的生命。我们非常清楚他们是有瑕疵的、充满细微差别的。但我们却认为自己必须完美，必须拥有所有的答案。这就是为什么前行会如此困难，尤其是因为我们似乎是唯一能够亲自且深刻地感受到过去带来的所有负面结果（尤其是那种内疚）的人。而我们并不会真正看到别人私底下的生活，也不知道他们自己私底下在进行多少自我惩罚。自我宽恕确实很棘手，但它也确实是继续前行的唯一途径，并且是一种如此积极的性格品质。你必须提醒自己，你真的已经根据你当时拥有的信息做出了最好的选择。没有人想把自己的生活过得更糟。大多数人并不想伤害别人或经历遗憾。我们并不想处于这种处境中。因此，如果我们当时就知道决定的结果，我们可能就不会那样做了。我们会做出不同的选择。但我们没有。我们当时并不知道会有什么后果。我们不得不做我们认为最好的事情，或者至少是最糟糕的情况下、我们觉得权宜之计的事情。而现在，正如俗话所说，米已成炊。你无法改变它。但你可以用……来取代它
bitterness and regret with compassion and with love for yourself. So, I want to explain how. How can we move on from past mistakes? But also, how can we actually learn from them rather than just sweeping it under the rug? All of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
带着同情与自我关爱，放下痛苦与遗憾。所以，我想解释一下如何做到这一点。我们该如何从过去的错误中走出来？同时，我们又该如何真正从中吸取教训，而不是将其束之高阁？这一切以及更多内容，将在短暂停留后为您揭晓。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养坚韧意志、保持健康以及建立心理弹性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家等进行对话，带您看透充斥在健康产业中不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out, on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
我们曾坚信种子油生来就会引起炎症。我们错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。就在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打小金的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex In. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s.
或者坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚克斯·伊恩。每一集里，我们都会在这里挑选一个事件，剖析事情的经过，并试着理解我们是如何熬过这一切的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔畅谈80年代瘾品的节目。
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
澄清一下，84对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为瘾品。我随时都可以聊聊瘾品，只要大家想听。我的意思是，马克，这是我们第二集讨论瘾品了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的主线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆上了台面。谢谢你把话说完。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您收听播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将结合十多年来在心理健康领域的个人经验，与众多不可思议的嘉宾进行对话。我说的是：特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，在我们追求某样东西的过程中，我们太过于沉迷于追逐本身，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
而我们却仍在追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是盯着记分牌。生活变成了胜负的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，既然你们觉得在世时做一个好人很重要，那么你们做一个好人是因为恐惧吗？因为老兄，这是两种不同的动机。绝对是。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app.
这也是两种不同层面的信任。我希望你们能真正做一个好人。加入我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，和我基尔·盖恩斯一起，就治愈、成长、父职、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。
Search, learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct?
搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法院听证会暴露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场历时多年的法庭之战，以证明真相。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试，对吗？
I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋，迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的大脑都要炸了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I think the first step towards self-forgiveness is realizing,
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨戴尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧恩斯终于要承担后果了。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧恩斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。我认为迈向自我宽恕的第一步是意识到，
like we said before, that you are not the same person you were a few years ago. You are not perpetually stuck at the age and the time you were when you made that mistake, especially if you're under the age of 30, like I'm sure many of you are. Your brain, like we said, wasn't even fully developed yet. You were in some ways still a child in an adult's body. Not only are you allowed to grow from that version of you and the version of you that may have been. misguided, but psychology basically demands that you do. One way to show this is by examining personality. Our personalities were often thought to be quite fixed and quite stagnant. Who you were at 18 is who you would be when you were 80. But we've now seen that that's totally false. Researchers have
正如我们之前所说，你已经不是几年前的那个你了。你并没有永远停留在犯错时的那个年龄和时期，特别是如果你不到30岁的话，我相信你们中的很多人都是如此。正如我们所说，你的大脑当时甚至还没有完全发育成熟。某种程度上，你依然是一个披着成人外衣的孩子。你不仅被允许从那个版本的自己（以及那个可能误入歧途的自己）身上成长，而且心理学基本上也要求你这样做。证明这一点的方法之一就是审视个性。我们的个性过去常常被认为是相当固定和停滞不前的。你18岁时是什么样的人，你80岁时就会是什么样的人。但我们现在发现这完全是错误的。研究人员
continuously proven over the last few decades that we are not the same person our whole life. In particular, we become, as we get older, a lot more conscientious, a lot more altruistic and agreeable, even more empathetic. Part of that change is also brought on by our past mistakes, whatever the nature of those may be. One of the biggest parts of forgiving yourself is choosing to accept the lesson from your decisions rather than only accepting the guilt. you can learn equally as much from the things you did wrong as you can from the things that you did right. And what that involves is an acknowledgement of what went wrong and the ways you may have
在过去几十年里不断证明，我们一生中并不是同一个人。特别是随着年龄的增长，我们会变得更有责任心、更有利他精神和随和度，甚至更有同理心。这种变化的部分原因也是由我们过去的错误引发的，无论这些错误的性质如何。宽恕自己最重要的一部分，是选择接受你的决定带来的教训，而不是只接受内疚。你从做错的事情中学到的东西，和从做对的事情中学到的一样多。这涉及承认哪里出了问题，以及你可能
acted in a matter that was not aligned to that ideal self. So think about it in terms of making a mistake and a new job. You send that email to the wrong person. Well, you know from now on you're going to triple check those email addresses. You said something really hurtful. to a friend. Well, you're now going to check yourself every time you're in a heated discussion because that regret is a very salient, emotional reminder of what you don't want to feel, which is that terrible dull ache of remorse. That's why we say regret is an important signal because it shows us when we've stepped out of line or acted in a way that we don't really agree with. So you need to listen to that feeling because it's,
以一种不符合理想自我的方式行事。所以，试着把它想象成在工作中犯了一个错误。你把那封电子邮件发给了错误的人。好吧，你从现在开始知道你会仔细检查那些电子邮件地址了。你对朋友说了一些非常伤人的话。好吧，你现在每次在激烈的讨论中都会自我克制，因为这种遗憾是一个非常突出的情感提醒，提醒你不想感受到那种感觉，也就是那种可怕而沉闷的懊悔之痛。这就是为什么我们说遗憾是一个重要的信号，因为它向我们展示了我们何时偏离了正轨，或者以一种我们并不真正认同的方式行事。所以你需要倾听这种感觉，因为它
telling you something important. And further to that, examine where the root of your behavior or that tendency has come from. Maybe it's emerged from how you were raised, how you were taught to treat others, past trauma, especially in romantic relationships. I hear about this all the time. People who lash out and push others away because of that fear of being hurt, only to realize that that person may have been really special. Maybe it's more pathological, like a compulsive tendency to lie or to oversell your capabilities.
在告诉你一些重要的事情。除此之外，还要检查你的行为或这种倾向的根源来自哪里。也许它源于你的成长经历、你被教导如何对待他人，过去的创伤，尤其是在恋爱关系中。我经常听到这种情况。人们因为害怕受到伤害而大发雷霆并将他人推开，结果却发现这个人可能非常特别。也许它更具病态，比如强迫性撒谎或过度推销自己能力的倾向。
There are so many possibilities. But really examining the origins of your mistake before you commit to fixing it is important because otherwise how can you kind of identify a repeat pattern? How can you learn from that? Part of that involves taking accountability and responsibility for your actions. That's really hard. because the first step is to admit your mistake, and that is difficult because we are very good at finding ways to protect our ego and maintain a positive self-image. So we unconsciously search for
可能性太多了。但在你致力于纠正错误之前，真正审视错误的根源是很重要的，因为否则你怎么能识别出重复的模式呢？你怎么能从中吸取教训呢？其中一部分包括对你的行为承担责任和交代。这真的很难，因为第一步是承认你的错误，这很困难，因为我们非常擅长寻找方法来保护自我并维持积极的自我形象。因此，我们在潜意识里寻找
excuses as to why we've acted in a certain way, both exogenous and endogenous. You know, we say things like, they started it. I just lost my call. I didn't think things through. I was drunk. yes, those are all valuable explanations, but at the end of the day, you still made a choice, and that's okay, you just have to own up to it. Everyone struggles with admitting that they've done something perhaps bad. It's only natural because if we truly thought that we were a terrible person or a failure, it would be very difficult to move on because of that all or nothing thinking. And that's where we get into trouble, because you can mess up and still have.
关于为什么我们以某种特定方式行事的借口，包括外在和内在的。你知道，我们会说这样的话：是他们先挑起的。我只是情绪失控了。我没有深思熟虑。我当时喝醉了。是的，这些都是有价值的解释，但归根结底，你仍然做出了选择，这没关系，你只需要勇于承担。每个人都在承认自己可能做了坏事这件事上挣扎。这很自然，因为如果我们真的认为自己是一个糟糕的人或是一个失败者，由于这种非黑即白的思维方式，我们将很难继续前行。这就是我们陷入困境的地方，因为你可能会把事情搞砸，但依然拥有
a lot of redeeming qualities, but one of those qualities cannot be ignorance, because denial is kind of how you get yourself into deeper trouble. I think a big part of maturing is realizing that you can embrace accountability rather than being scared of it, and it will probably leave you better off. I was having this discussion with a friend the other day who was telling me how she made a mistake at work, and her boss kind of called her out for it. And her first reaction was to be like, oh my God, he's such an asshole. He's so cranky, so uptight. But we had this discussion of being like, deciding that here's the problem isn't going to make your life easier. It's not going to change the outcome. You kind of have to take it on the nose, absorb the
很多闪光点，但其中一个品质绝不能是无知，因为逃避现实正是让你陷入更深困境的方式。我认为走向成熟的一个重要部分是意识到你可以拥抱责任，而不是对它感到害怕，这可能会让你过得更好。前几天我和一个朋友讨论这件事，她告诉我她在工作中犯了一个错误，她的老板有点因此指责了她。她的第一反应是觉得：天哪，他真是个混蛋。他太暴躁、太拘谨了。但我们讨论后发现，认定问题出在这里并不能让你的生活变得更轻松。它不会改变结果。你只能硬着头皮接受，并吸收
feedback, and choose to be better. The same goes for more serious things like cheating as an example. if you cheat on someone, and obviously not speaking from personal experience, but if you do, you can either choose to put that guilt and that shame back onto your partner or you can choose to be better. You can say to yourself, okay, I messed up here. I feel guilty. What is that telling me about my actions? And make the conscious choice to not be that person, to not be that version of yourself in the future.
反馈，并选择变得更好。更严重的事情也是如此，比如出轨。如果你背叛了某人——显然我不是在根据个人经历来说——但如果你真的这么做了，你要么选择把那种内疚和羞耻感重新加诸于你的伴侣，要么你可以选择变得更好。你可以对自己说，好吧，我搞砸了。我感到很内疚。这说明了我的行为有什么问题？然后有意识地选择不再成为那样的人，在未来不再成为那种版本的自己。
Or, you know, you can avoid the regret. you can move on to the next person, do it again, break someone else's heart, be the villain. It doesn't eradicate the original mistake. And the thing is nothing will. The only thing that matters at that point is the future. So you want to make sure the future version of yourself is one that takes accountability and does better. And part of that is this really simple equation for self-forgiveness that I think we should all be following because it really allows us to humanize our mistakes and show self-compassion and move forward. It's called the four
或者，你知道的，你可以逃避遗憾。你可以走向下一个人，再来一次，再去伤别人的心，去做那个恶人。这并不能消除最初的犯下的错误。问题在于，没有什么能做到这一点。在那一刻，唯一重要的事情就是未来。所以你要确保未来版本的自己是一个勇于承担责任并做得更好的人。这其中包含了一个非常简单的自我原谅公式，我认为我们都应该遵循它，因为它确实能让我们把错误人性化，展现自我同情并继续前行。它被称为四个
hours of self-forgiveness. So they are responsibility, remorse, restoration, and renewal. We've already spoken about responsibility, which I think is very much synonymous with accountability, but basically you have to be honest with yourself or with others that you made a mistake and you are responsible for your own actions. Secondly, there's remorse. This is particularly important if the decisions that you made have impacted someone else. Express what you're feeling, say that you feel bad, that you know you made the wrong choice, that you don't like how the outcome is turned out, but you take responsibility that you are the one who's caused it, or if it's a mistake that's impacting you and you alone, that you know you made a mistake and you
自我原谅的要素。它们是：责任、悔恨、修复和更新。我们已经讨论过责任了，我认为这在很大程度上与担当是同义词，但基本上你必须对自己或他人诚实，承认你犯了错误，并且你要为自己的行为负责。其次是悔恨。如果你做出的决定已经影响到了其他人，这一点尤为重要。表达你的感受，说你感到很糟糕，你知道自己做错了选择，你不喜欢这样的结果，但你承担起责任，承认这是你造成的；或者如果这个错误只影响了你一个人，你知道自己犯了错，并且
feel sorry. Allow yourself to feel those negative feelings associated with responsibility, whether it's kind of letting go of guilt or shame. Both of those things need to be channeled into remorse. You cannot forgive yourself or move on if you suppress those negative feelings because you haven't fully accepted what's happened and your role in the outcome. This is when we get to restoration, which is kind of like the beginning of the healing phase. An important part of forgiving yourself is making amends for your mistakes. If it's needed, make a genuine apology to those people or that person that you've heard. This takes away the feeling of wishing that you could have done more in the future. The worst feeling is knowing that you've
感到抱歉。让自己去感受那些与责任相关的负面情绪，无论是释放内疚还是羞耻。这两者都需要被引导转化为悔恨。如果你压抑这些负面情绪，你就无法原谅自己或继续前行，因为你还没有完全接受所发生的事情以及你在结果中所扮演的角色。这就是我们要讲到修复的时候，这有点像治愈阶段的开始。原谅自己的一个重要部分是为你的错误进行弥补。如果需要的话，向那些你伤害过的人或那个人真诚地道歉。这消除了那种希望自己未来能做更多事情的感觉。最糟糕的感觉是明知自己
messed up and bearing your head in the sand, being like, I don't want to feel like a bad person. So I'm going to forget this ever happened. And then six months a year, goes by, that feeling's still there. You haven't actually taken accountability. And I think it also is really important because at this stage, like we said, you can't change the outcome, but you can change how you conclude the story, how you make someone else feel. And leaving things better than before also allows you to close that chapter, knowing that you've done the right thing and that you do deserve to move on from it. Or if it's a mistake that's impacting you, you can apologize to you. to yourself, acknowledge the context in which the decision was made and that you did what felt right
搞砸了却把头埋在沙子里，心里想：我不想觉得自己是个坏人。所以我打算假装这一切从来没发生过。然后六个月、一年过去了，那种感觉依然存在。你并没有真正承担责任。而且我认为这真的很重要，因为在这个阶段，就像我们所说的，你无法改变结果，但你可以改变你如何为这个故事收尾，如何让别人感觉好受一些。把事情处理得比以前更好，也能让你合上这一页，知道自己做了正确的事，并且你确实配得上继续前行。或者，如果这是一个只影响你自己的错误，你可以向自己道歉，
and now you know better. It's time to move forward. So finally we have renewal. What are you going to change about yourself, your motivations and your actions to do better next time? An important part of that I've found is to really articulate what you want your ideal self to be. Who does this person look like knowing what you know now. Write down how they act, how they make others feel, how people respond to them. Are they honest? Are they more empathetic? Are they more cautious? Do they ask for help when they need it? I really want you to visualize this person and question how you can align your current behavior with what your best self, your ideal self, would be doing. It's even better if you can make those thoughts tangible by writing them down or even typing them into your notes up, someplace that
承认做出这个决定时的背景，并且你当时做了感觉正确的事，而现在你懂得了更多。是时候前行了。所以最后我们有了更新。为了下次做得更好，你将对自己的自我、动机和行为做出什么改变？我发现其中的一个重要部分是，真正清晰地表达出你希望自己成为一个怎样的理想自我。结合你现在所知道的一切，这个人会是什么样子。写下他们的行为举止，他们如何让别人感觉舒适，人们如何回应他们。他们诚实吗？他们更有同理心吗？他们更谨慎吗？他们在需要时会寻求帮助吗？我真的很想让你把这个人可视化，并思考如何让你的行为与你的最佳自我、你的理想自我保持一致。如果你能把这些想法具体化，把它们写下来，或者甚至打字记录在你的笔记应用里，放在某个
you can revisit and return to kind of when you want to receive your own wisdom or guidance, because typically we trust our opinion the most. There's no point punishing yourself forever at this stage. It's not going to fix the situation. In fact, it's just going to keep you stuck in those memories in that moment. It goes without saying that it's not up to you to decide whether someone else forgives you as well. Your emotional reaction and theirs do not have to be aligned for you to acknowledge that pain and move forward. Let them say their peace, let them have their response and actually listen. It's uncomfortable, I know, but you owe it to them. And also you owe it to yourself. No feeling can be passed. No feeling can be processed without being felt. Finally, it's
你可以重新访问和回顾的地方，比如当你想要汲取自己的智慧或指导时，那会更好，因为通常我们最信任自己的意见。在这个阶段，永远惩罚自己是没有意义的。这并不能修复现状。事实上，它只会让你一直困在那些记忆和那一刻中。不言而喻的是，别人是否原谅你，也不是由你决定的。你的情感反应和他们的反应不需要保持一致，你也可以承认那种痛苦并继续前行。让他们倾诉他们的想法，让他们做出反应并真正去倾听。我知道这很不舒服，但你欠他们的。同时，这也是你欠自己的。没有哪种感受是可以被跳过的。任何感受如果不去真切体验，就无法被消化。最后，
valuable to think about how you treat others when they make mistakes and, well, treat them how you would want to be treated and then treat yourself accordingly. It's this idea known as shared humanity, acknowledging that some parts of the human experience are very much universal. Everyone makes mistakes, everyone experiences setbacks. You are not the only one going through this, probably at this very moment. And imagining how you would treat a good friend in this situation or a younger sibling, you would probably do so with a lot of compassion. So it kind of goes without saying, why don't you deserve the same? I think that's a beautiful reminder to end on. As someone who also struggles with feeling a lot of guilt and regret over the past,
思考你如何对待犯错误的其他人是很有价值的，好吧，用你希望被对待的方式去对待他们，然后相应地对待你自己。这就是所谓的“共享人性”的概念，承认人类体验中的某些部分在很大程度上是普遍的。每个人都会犯错，每个人都会经历挫折。你不是唯一一个经历这一切的人，可能此时此刻也是如此。想象一下，在这种情况下你会如何对待一个好朋友或一个年轻的弟弟妹妹，你可能会抱有极大的同情心。所以这不言而喻，为什么你就不值得同样的对待呢？我认为这是一个美丽的提醒，适合作为结束语。作为一个同样在过去感受到很多内疚和遗憾而挣扎的人，
I really do understand how mentally exhausting it is to feel like your identity is no more than your past mistakes, but it is more. It is so much more, especially when we choose to learn and grow and be better rather than overwhelm ourselves with self-pity and the what-ifs. No one has had a go at being human before. There is no guidebook and human emotion, a lot of things in life are tricky. So just do the best you can with what you have, have an open mind about accepting failure and accountability, recognize that you will grow. You are a different person now. I just really think you can't do more than that. You really can't. You just kind of have to live with it and know that in time it will pass, you will have a greater perspective on why maybe this mistake needed to happen, why you needed
我真的理解，觉得自己的人生无非就是过去犯下的错误，这种感觉在精神上是多么令人精疲力竭，但事实并非如此。它远比这丰富得多，尤其是当我们选择学习、成长并变得更好，而不是用自怜和“如果当初”来压垮自己时。以前没有人当过人类。这里没有一本使用指南，人类的情感以及生活中的很多事情都是棘手的. 所以，用你现有的条件做到最好，以开放的心态去接受失败和责任，认识到你会成长。你现在已经是一个不同的人了。我真的认为你做不了更多了。你真的做不到。你只能接受这一切，并知道时间会抚平一切，你会有更广阔的视角去理解为什么这个错误可能需要发生，为什么你需要
to mess up, the lesson that you needed to learn. It all comes together in the future. So thank you so much for listening to today's episode. I really hope you took something valuable from this. And if there is someone else who you think would take something from this, please feel free to share it with them. I think radical self-compassion, self-forgiveness are really important. We cannot punish ourselves forever. Like I keep. saying. I think that is a huge part of my daily philosophy these days. So hopefully that resonated with you as well. As always, if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts on Spotify, wherever this episode is coming to you from. It really helps the show to
把事情搞砸，以及你需要从中吸取什么教训。这一切都会在未来融会贯通。非常感谢大家收听今天的节目。我真心希望你们能从中获得宝贵的东西。如果你觉得还有其他人会从中受益，请随时分享给他们。我认为激进的自我同情和自我原谅真的非常重要。我们不能永远惩罚自己。就像我一直说的那样。我认为这如今占据了我日常哲学很大的一部分。所以希望这也引起了你们的共鸣。一如既往，如果你喜欢这期节目，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或收听本节目的任何平台上留下五星好评。这真的对节目的成长和
grow and reach a new audience. I've spoken about my Patreon before as well. But like I say, it does take a lot of work to make this show. It is just me writing these episodes, researching them, recording them, editing them. It's a lot of work. And I really do appreciate the additional support. And you also get bonus content from me all the time. I do sometimes spam people there with bonus episodes and newsletters and transcripts. So check it out if you would like.
触及新的受众很有帮助。我之前也谈到过我的Patreon。但就像我说的，制作这个节目确实需要大量的工作。写这些节目脚本、做研究、录音、剪辑，全都是我一个人。这工作量很大。我真的很感激大家额外的支持。而且你还可以一直从我这里获得独家内容。我有时会在那里向大家发送独家单集节目、时事通讯和文字稿来刷屏。如果你感兴趣，可以去看看。
And if you have an episode suggestion, send me a DM at that psychology podcast. I love hearing what you guys are going through and how that relates to some of the universal psychology and experiences of our 20s. So thank you for listening and we will be back next week with another episode. Hey, what's good y'all? You're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not.
如果你有节目建议，请在私信里发给我，账号是“that psychology podcast”。我喜欢听你们正在经历的事情，以及这与我们二十岁时普遍的心理学体验有何关联。谢谢大家的收听，我们下周将推出另一期节目。嘿，大家好！欢迎收听“艰难求生”（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人克尔·甘斯（Kear Games）。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行真诚的对话——这些对话在其他任何地方谈论都不安全，但在这里，你是在和一位懂行的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人披着一副盔甲？它向世界释放出一种信号：你可不是
to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Sond's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini.
好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有能力，就必须这样做。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听“艰难求生”。在2023年，“钻石单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下了一对双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。“桑兹女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？”“我伪造了一次测试。”这需要大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人：格雷格、莱斯利、迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是“受困之爱”（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听“受困之爱”播客。2%。这是当电梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客“2%”中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听“2%”。这就是数字“2”_percent。
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, They take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约定时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个iHeart播客。保证是由真人制作的。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。